all right joining us now we have a lot
to get to tonight the author of the book
the case against the Democratic House
impeaching Trump professor Harvard
professor Alan Dershowitz and also Fox
News correspondent at-large Harada
Rivera
you know Geraldo you so passionate last
night and so you reminded me of the
police important I've said last night I
thought that was the best news
conference I watched in my career he was
so good in describing the impact when
people lie first of all I'm honored to
be on with two of my best friends you
and professor Dershowitz it's it's an
honor I thought that the police
superintendent in Chicago Eddie Johnson
saved the reputation of the city the
same voice to the partisans on both
sides in this in this troubling issue I
think we cannot lose sight of what this
is this is a cynical selfish exploitive
young man who shamed the history of true
victims of race crimes in this country
by his cavalier staging of this event
it's a it reminds me a lot of OJ Simpson
you know not as serious because no one
died but the mountain of evidence
against him and the bizarre nature of
the partisans who are continuing to
support him in the face of this mountain
of evidence is is similar it's a there's
no logic to it
it's infuriating smollett is going to
get his just deserts I think that people
will abandon him eventually but it is
pretty clear from the evidence as we
know it that this man sought to exploit
the racial tensions in this country for
his own financial gain it's disgusting
it's lowdown and dirty I I don't think
his career what I would do or I him is
just go to a tropical island chill out
for a couple of years then come back and
crawl on your belly and apologize well
the American people he's now got to be
tried and there might be a federal
aspect to this coming that are not long
after professor I'm very consistent the
evidence now mounting and mounting and
mounting in the videos and everything
associated with it what are your
thoughts
well you know the hard left is perfectly
willing to demand the presumption of
innocence as they should for Smollett
but they weren't prepared to give a
presumption of innocence to the
non-existent Magga hat-wearing
assailants they immediately assume the
story was true immediately convicted
these people in the court of public
opinion and so what we see is the
presumption of innocence like so many
other aspects of our life is selectively
employed by the left against the right
sometimes by the right against the left
we have to have a presumption of
innocence on both sides and you and your
monologue set that out correctly you
said we have to assume Smollett to be
innocent but look at the evidence it is
certainly mounting now I believe
strongly because I've been a victim
myself of this when somebody
deliberately frames somebody and
deliberately makes up a false report of
anything that person must go to jail the
integrity of the system demands that
deliberate false report is not if you
made an act not if you made a mistake in
honest mistake but deliberate false
reporters must go to jail you know the
Bible says that if you testify falsely
against somebody you get the penalty
that that person would have gotten one
of the big head professor T and if you
hide that here you would see that these
this guy should get the penalty that the
assailants would have gotten if they
were real and existed but what is really
really I'm worried though professor I
don't want to roll it away
they really are racist vile vicious
racists in this country there are
horrible people that would hurt innocent
people because of their sexual
orientation
there are look at a congresswoman that
is a virulent anti-semite that sits on a
Foreign Affairs Committee still now
that's not acceptable to me professor
Nam sets out to mate you know when you
hear somebody says when you hear
somebody say that the mag Ahad is a
trigger that is such a phony excuse but
some people the Star of David is a
trigger but some people that crosses a
trigger for some people seeing a gay
couple together or an interracial couple
as a trigger mind you this is people who
are racist based on trigger
that they don't like that's just wrong
and what is unforgivable is that all of
the smart people who are blind to the
evidence because it fits their political
narrative to think that the original
fake story was true
they hate Trump so much that they're
seeking to justify even this absolutely
impossible story
all right amazing commentary from both
today it's used against them tomorrow it
could be used against you true you're
right
100% very well said both of you thank
you